pues sí
[Música]
el verano intenso que está azotando al
sur de europa parece ser poco si lo
comparamos con la forma como está
ardiendo la política italiana este país
del sur de el continente está otra vez
envuelto en una crisis política de
divisiones intereses políticos mientras
la coyuntura nacional e internacional
pide más que nunca unidad soluciones y
sobre todo decisiones la política
italiana está dividida entre pedirle al
primer ministro mario draghi que
continúe al frente del país o cambiar la
mayoría que lo sostiene en el gobierno
dejando entonces de lado al partido
movimiento cinco estrellas o dar por
finalizada la legislatura terminar con
la coalición y adelantar las elecciones
en italia en este momento todos los
escenarios son factibles pero quién es
mario draghi este experimentado político
italiano que ha tenido un amplio fogueo
en el en el escenario internacional ha
sido clave para la estabilización de ese
país veamos más detalles en el siguiente
informe
con el apodo de supermario se esperaba
que mario draghi pudiera ser el que
sacara italia de una serie de crisis fue
en febrero del año pasado cuando este
hombre de 74 años aceptó formar un nuevo
gobierno reconociendo importantes retos
el momento difícil es un momento difícil
el presidente ha hablado de la dramática
crisis sanitaria y de sus graves efectos
en la vida de las personas en la
economía en la sociedad la gravedad de
la emergencia exige respuestas que estén
a la altura
la concepto de la emergencia ricky de
disparos de la arteria de la situación
draghi asumió el cargo de primer
ministro después de que el último
gobierno de italia presidido por
giuseppe conte se hundiera en enero tras
perder la mayoría en el senado
draghi pasó días reuniendo un gobierno
de unidad nacional y contaba con una
amplia gama de partidos desde el
movimiento antisistema cinco estrellas
hasta la liga de extrema derecha una de
las razones por las que tantos de ellos
unieron fuerzas es que todos querían
tener voz y voto en la forma en la que
italia gastaba los más de doscientos mil
millones de euros de los fondos de
recuperación de la unión europea mario
draghi es una figura muy conocida en las
finanzas italianas de 1984 a 1990 fue
director ejecutivo del banco mundial y
después pasó por goldman sachs y el
banco de italia en 2011 fue nombrado
presidente del banco central europeo
cargo que ocupó hasta 2019 en este
puesto se le atribuye el mérito de haber
sacado al euro del borde del colapso
durante la crisis de la deuda soberana
haciendo su ya famosa promesa de hacer
lo que sea necesario
pues mario draghi aceptó gobernar a
italia en febrero del 2021 a cambio de
hacerlo con una coalición de unidad que
estaría activa hasta marzo del 2023 año
en el que se debe convocar a elecciones
en italia pero ante el retiro del
partido movimiento 5 estrellas la
continuidad del gobierno la misión de
unidad de la coalición se dio por
terminada es por ello que el premier
acudió entonces al jefe del estado a
sergio mataré la y le presentó su
dimisión pero ésta fue rechazada que
sigue entonces para mario draghi que
sigue para italia está la estabilidad
política de italia y de europa en jaque
lo vamos a analizar en unos minutos aquí
en france24 y para ello hemos invitado
al programa armando garcía él es
internacionalista de la universidad
nacional autonoma de mexico también es
magíster de la universidad autónoma de
barcelona en cataluña españa él se
conecta desde la ciudad de méxico desde
la capital de la república mexicana y
desde bogotá en colombia se une a esta
conversación mario aller san millán él
es docente de la cátedra de relaciones
internacionales de la pontificia
universidad avellana que está ubicada en
la ciudad de bogotá en la capital
colombiana les recuerdo que ustedes
también hacen parte de esta conversación
por supuesto pueden dejar sus preguntas
y sus comentarios a través de las redes
sociales
estamos en twitter en instagram y
también en facebook en donde no se
encuentran como france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
también les cuento que en youtube pueden
seguir nuestra señal en streaming y
también aprovecho para saludar a las
personas que nos escuchan a través de
nuestro podcast los invito para que
escuchen todos los contenidos de nuestro
programa que ya están disponibles en app
el podcast en spotify deezer y tienen
bueno pues comienzo entonces con armando
en la ciudad de mexico primero dándole
la bienvenida armando gracias por estar
con nosotros en el programa punto de
partida como me gusta a mí llamar a la
primera pregunta para conocer posiciones
de los invitados y un poco como hacíamos
la promoción del programa está la
estabilidad de italia y de europa en
jaque con este esta crisis que se está
presentando en italia un país que de vez
en cuando le da dolores de cabeza a
bruselas buenas tardes santiago el
placer es mío estar aquí con ustedes es
importante recordar que esta
inestabilidad política no es nueva en
italia entonces tampoco es un escenario
que sea novedoso para europa y para el
el pueblo italiano simplemente recordar
que en los últimos desde 1994 italia ha
tenido diez primeros ministros a la
cabeza de 16 gobiernos diferentes
por ahí en el escenario europeo se habla
del excepcionalismo italiano respecto a
que la política italiana siempre cultiva
estas crisis para poder salir cierto es
que el contexto es diferente en este
escenario de la guerra de la invasión
rusa ucrania la inestabilidad económica
respecto a una posible recesión y
añadiríamos el tema de la crisis
climática con los incendios que se
encuentran en el sur de europa
particularmente como bien mencionaban en
italia en roma en la capital y entonces
la inestabilidad política no es algo que
no conozca italia
pasó a hacerle la misma pregunta a mario
en la ciudad de bogotá mar yo también
los saludo gracias por acompañarnos hoy
en el programa punto de partida la
estabilidad de italia y de europa
también podría estar en jaque con esta
crisis esta nueva crisis que presenta
italia
bueno primero buenas tardes santiago
buenas tardes armando y coincido pues
prácticamente en su totalidad con lo que
he hecho armando asusta porque tal día
pues siempre cambia cada poco el
ministro se queda un gobierno o se monta
otro pero italia no desaparece entonces
quizás tenemos que ver que es una virtud
está digamos
variación que manteniendo pensemos que
draghi lleva ahora en el cargo pero el
ministro vamos más o menos una entre
unas cosas y otras año y medio
y su antecesor conté él pues estuvo dos
años no llegó a 32 años largos pero con
dos gobiernos diferentes
el
anterior
a conté gentiloni pues estuvo también lo
que llevaba más o menos ahora draghi un
año y medio más o menos su anterior
rennes y estuvo
[Música]
y
una república en las cualidades del año
46 1946 se pues que la persona que más
tiempo ha estado en el gobierno ha sido
silvio berlusconi que ha estado nueve
años pero en cuatro gobiernos diferentes
son cuatro etapas diferentes entonces es
en parte habitual que esté en tan poco
tiempo y no por ello debe suponer un
mero mayor del que había antes de que
ocurriera esta crisis de gobierno que se
usaba más bien por los partidos en este
caso cinco estrellas que se están auto
impresionando dejó sobre la mesa armando
y mário este tema de esta forma de
gobernar en italia de estos estas crisis
que se van sucediendo una tras otra
para poder salir un poco más fortalecido
o para que el país tome algún tipo de
decisión importante luego lo dejó sobre
la mesa quiero ir a lo que nos trae al
punto de partida del programa de hoy que
es precisamente como lo mencionaba mario
con quien sigo para hacer la ronda a la
inversa
la decisión del movimiento cinco
estrellas que no es necesariamente no
han dicho oficialmente que se retiran de
la coalición pero sí que le quitan el
apoyo
ministro son dos cosas distintas que es
lo que lleva al movimiento cinco
estrellas a este escenario que es lo que
se está gestando hacia el interior de
esa coalición y del partido
la coalición es una cosa el partido
cinco estrellas es otra y lo que ocurre
en cinco estrellas es que digamos que
está implosionando por dentro él salió
como partido entre los dos nuevos
partidos protesta por llamarlos de la
nueva política y lo que ocurre es que
parecía que estaba bien estaban
centrados pero ahora con la guerra de
ucrania han empezado a haber voces
discordantes a las voces discordantes
dentro del partido sobre todo porque si
apoyo irrestricto a ucrania o realmente
debemos pensar y ser más sosegados
porque estamos viendo las orejas al logo
en el sentido que vemos que los altos
costes de energía pues nos pueden
repercutir y ellos dentro del partido
pues tienen bronca
de mayo el líder diríamos tradicional
pues
se ha ido has hecho ya en que usar una
de vosotros entonces lo que ha quedado
pues es como cualquier grupo o cualquier
empresa cualquier partido cuando se va
asumida están desconcertados y no hay
una sola voz dos tiene bar la voz
cantante entonces lo que ocurre es que
se están auto acomodando y la coalición
todos los partidos que ahora mismo otra
que instalar con siete si no estoy mal
contando a cinco estrellas
pues están buscando los otros seis de
como reacomodarse como para poder ganar
poder dentro de la coalición para
maximizar y ocupar el espacio que puede
dejar vacío cinco estrellas claro le
pregunta ahora armando en ciudad de
méxico mario utiliza el término
implosionar qué ventajas puede tener
para cinco estrellas provocar esta
crisis implosionar al interior del
partido y afectar la coalición llevar al
gobierno a este punto límite en una
coyuntura tan complicada para europa y
para el país
claro ventajas como tal yo tampoco veo
es concuerdo con con mario' es más bien
una consecuencia de la naturaleza del
movimiento cinco estrellas recordemos su
llegada al poder en 2018 como un partido
antisistema y la naturaleza de estos
partidos anti sistemas en términos de
ser más o menos jerárquicos más
horizontales y como bien decía mario
todo mundo quiere
un poco de vos no en términos de liderar
justamente así que yo creo que no es una
consecuencia en este tipo de la
naturaleza del partido antisistema
porque ventajas no veo ahora porque los
movimientos cinco estrellas justamente
de 2018 para acá ha ido perdiendo la
preferencia de los votantes italianos si
hubiera un adelanto de elecciones el
movimiento de cinco estrellas saldría
más raspado que ganador porque en las
preferencias electorales se han movido
justamente hacia la derecha en italia
retomo un poco lo que mencionabas en
términos del debate y lo que decía mario
la decisión en el movimiento cinco
estrellas
un grupo que se ha salido de este de
este partido para apoyar la continuidad
de draghi para continuar en la en la
legislatura justamente claro importante
ese punto importante aquí vamos ya
armando poco a poco el rompecabezas de
la política italiana una política que
américa latina no está muy familiarizada
para para entenderla me parece
importante estos puntos que están
tocando
es una de las preguntas que nos hacíamos
al interior de la redacción presentando
y preparando este programa era
justamente lo que ustedes estaban
comentando al inicio cuando hicieron la
respuesta del punto de partida armando y
es esta facilidad que tiene italia de
cada cierto tiempo entrar en estas
pequeñas o grandes crisis para renovar
su gobierno para tomar decisiones
trascendentales o forzar al país a dar
un paso adelante porque es tan difícil
mantener un gobierno estable en italia
porque solamente una figura como
berlusconi con cuatro gobiernos
diferentes logró permanecer en el poder
nueve años como lo explicaba mario
el hecho de que berlusconi sea la
persona con más tiempo en el poder nos
explica mucho de la política italiana
hay que recordar tener como punto de
partida que una de las razones
fundamentales del funcionamiento de la
política italiana es del sistema
electoral que prima la proporcionalidad
que da como resultado una representación
muy similar en el parlamento y por lo
tanto esta fragmentación de las familias
políticas que terminan buscando un
y aglutinador en el caso de silvio
berlusconi en el tiempo que estuvo no
por eso hablamos del excepcionalismo
italiano en italia después de la segunda
guerra mundial no estuvo tan presente en
lo que sí estuvo en el resto de europa
occidental que llamamos la conjunción de
centros la centroizquierda la
centroderecha en italia como para evitar
la presencia del partido comunista
justamente la idea de esta fragmentación
política con un centro con un guía
justamente que llevara las riendas de la
política en su momento fue silvio
berlusconi y hoy no ha tenido el
gobierno italiano lo buscaba con draghi
por este reconocimiento que tenía en
términos de los círculos económicos
dentro de italia en europa y al exterior
por supuesto
pero aquí se cansó de estas batallas en
términos electorales justamente claro
mário usted habla al mando menciona aquí
el tema de la fragmentación usted
mencionaba en mayo el tema de las
discrepancias que hay al interior del
gobierno sobre la invasión de rusia a
ucrania una invasión que está afectando
a toda la unión europea prácticamente
por igual como
como se entiende esa esa posición esa
fragmentación al interior que es tan
dividida hasta italia políticamente en
torno a la posición que debe tener el
país para hacer frente a esta guerra que
se está presentando en el este mar yo
es la divisiones dentro del movimiento
cinco estrellas la relación la razón
principal porque está como os decía
implosionando es porque digamos que se
puso en a discutir si debían apoyar
irrestrictamente la posición europea
sobre respecto a la grava la invasión
rusa de ucrania o no entonces es donde
empezó el problema y digamos que la
sociedad italiana pues está dividida
como cualquier otra sociedad europea el
sentido de que inicialmente sí apoyó al
débil en este caso ucrania porque la ha
invadido del abuso rusia después le
apoyó pero llega un momento en el que
los apoyos se ya no son tan inmediato se
empiezan a replantear y a ver un poco
más allá las consecuencias de a dónde de
dónde me puede llevar mi apoyo y lo que
comentaba es un poquito tanto tu
santiago como como armando muy
importante entrar y es una persona que
no no pertenece a ningún partido les
independiente
y de ahí tiene muchísimo prestigio fue
el hombre que pues que ahora hace las
obras que viene fue crisis de julio de
2012 hace 10 años que por decirlo se le
conoce como el hombre que salvó al euro
claro porque una conferencia y el
discurso de hacer guardia very takes lo
que lo que sea necesario lo que haga
falta que se volvió una frase muy famosa
y muy popular en italia usted sí
justamente como si tuviera mis notas en
sus manos leyó cuál era mi siguiente
pregunta para hacerle mario y es
justamente el papel que ha tenido mario
draghi para la historia política de
italia la coyuntura en la que él asumió
a liderar este gobierno después de una
serie de elecciones y unos fracasos
políticos muy grandes quiero que entre
ustedes dos armemos en el personaje
quién es él y que ha representado para
italia y por qué hay tantos sectores
políticos y sociales pidiendo como sea
enviando cartas haciendo llamados a
través de las redes sociales para que
draghi no deje el poder comenzó entonces
con armando para alternar
al invitado
ok más allá de esta cuestión económica
que viene él recordó mario el papel
respecto a la salvación del euro también
habría que recordar obtener el contexto
el escenario actual en europa donde
draghi ha figurado un eje nuevo con
macrón recordemos macrón el presidente
francés de esta la liberal en donde se
inserta draghi justamente no somos de un
par de los partidos tradicionales
clásicos del centroderecha
centroizquierda sino estamos más
enfocados en resolver los problemas de
ahí viene la el reconocimiento que tiene
draghi como un político que hace
política para resolver problemas en
términos de los problemas más
reales más directos de la ciudadanía que
tienen que ver con la economía y aquí
podría también un paréntesis un
asterisco respecto a por qué el
movimiento cinco estrellas es de retirar
su confianza no porque tiene que ver con
las propuestas de draghi respecto a cómo
enfrentar las crisis de la inflación y
la posible precisión en y tal en europa
en general
mario en su opinión
pues coincide en gran parte con los
hechos mando pero quería señalar una
cosa es esa esa similitud que ha
señalado de draghi com a chrome no ha
gustado tanto porque en macro sí que es
digamos un político profesional antes de
ser presidentes fue ministro todo carlos
pero draghi no trae es una persona que
lo el único cargo por ciclo olímpico por
si llamarlo que tuvo él fue gobernador
del banco de italia que es un cargo
independiente del nómina el gobierno no
ha presentado independiente fue el muy
cargo político tuvo en italia luego pues
pasó a ser gobernador del banco central
europeo y es donde se hizo famoso el no
tener ningún cargo orgánico en la
política italiana y parte de este lío
que resulta en latinoamérica a ver la
política italiana al ser un sistema
parlamentario que no como aquí que son
los presidencialismos es un sistema que
funciona de manera diferente en la
realidad del gobierno pues no está tan
tan tan tan garantizada como en un
sistema presidencialista donde teniendo
el presidente
entonces draghi no le hace falta
realmente ser el presidente del consejo
de ministros que se llama al cargo en
italia no hace falta él le hicieron un
encargo y él dijo bueno pues antes de
que todo se vaya al garete pues me voy a
poner aquí y ahora a presentar la
emisión básicamente por lo mismo serio
que los partidos con los que estaba
tratando trabajar pues están loco porque
cinco estrellas había impresionado a los
otros querían están dándose codazos por
quién gana más y dijo mira me paro tipo
me parecéis un patio de colegio yo no
quiero saber nada allá vosotros a mí
esto no me hace falta matar el a soy
matar en la filas reciente toma todo de
presentar la dimisión porque yo no
quiero jugar con los niños
me voy a retirar que ya tomada para
jubilarme mario y en ese en ese panorama
que usted explica no estaría cinco
estrellas tratando de desestabilizar el
gobierno la coalición y provocar que
draghi deje el gobierno para que llegue
a alguien un poco más afín a ellos puede
ser un escenario
si cinco estrellas fuera un movimiento
único el sentido de cohesionado bien
podríamos decir eso pero lo es la señal
armando algo mucho más horizontal
entonces no podemos decir que cinco
estrellas en su conjunto le estén
moviendo la cama draghi para que se
caerá la orden realidad ellos mismos se
están moviendo en su propia cama la de
ellos y almuerza la de dioses están
provocando que try ese arte y se vaya
claro así que indirectamente hay gente
dentro de cinco estrellas que le está
moviendo la cama draghi pero no el
partido en su conjunto porque no está
cohesionado ahora mismo porque tiene
problemas sí y armando en ciudad de
méxico la pregunta del millón de dólares
qué pasa si mario draghi se va que pasa
con italia qué pasa con la política
italiana en esta coyuntura en la que
está el país
buena pregunta habría que diferenciar si
me entendemos con que draghi se va
quiere decir que se acepta su dimensión
porque no sigue en el cargo hay dos
opciones el presidente material la
convoca elecciones
para otoño y lo cual se creo que sería
un escenario un poco complicado porque
hoy en día el bloque de la derecha y la
ultraderecha podría llegar al 45 por
ciento de los votos es decir hacerse del
poder en uno de los países fundadores y
más grandes de la unión europea este
sería el escenario más complicado desde
mi punto de vista el segundo escenario
es aceptar la dimisión de draghi pero
formar un nuevo gobierno que termine la
legislatura el marzo del 2023 y este
nuevo gobierno podría ser liderado por
algún
tecnócrata o algún político de alguno de
los partidos que siguen apoyando a la
coalición de unidad nacional
y mario su opinión sobre este posible
escenario si draghi se va que teoría
puede poner está sobre la mesa estoy de
acuerdo
fue muy entonces lo más posible es que
se busque una persona aséptica por así
decirlo a un tecnócrata para que digamos
logre agotar este medio año largo y
queda antes de convocar unas nuevas
elecciones
no creo que se la jueguen mataré la que
es por decirlo zorro viejo entro a la
política a unas elecciones ahora según
está el ambiente político donde la
derecha y ultraderecha puede ganar puede
conseguir tocar gobierno la ultraderecha
entonces no creo que vaya por ahí buscar
a una persona
aséptica que no se le acepten todos y
que nadie el incómodo para que agote la
legislatura
y en este tiempo
buscar cambiar de opinión derecha suelta
la derecha pierda estos apoyos claro
está ganando la ultraderecha es a río
revuelto está ganando si está ganando
está ganando posiciones y está ganando
el lidera desde hace mucho tiempo
algunas encuestas que han hecho a nivel
ciudadano justamente a eso me quería
referir armando al apoyo ciudadano
muchos italianos están muy conformes con
el primer ministro ha habido cartas de
los rectores de las principales
universidades ha habido mensajes a
través de los medios de comunicación
alcaldes de las principales ciudades
italianas de roma milán venecia
florencia pidiendo que me bragg y no
deja el poder puede de pronto este esta
presión ciudadana presión del pueblo
italiano
convencer a draghi de no pasar su carta
de renuncia el miércoles ante el
parlamento donde tiene que dar
explicación de su posición y por qué se
quiere dedicar cuáles son sus razones
armando usted cómo lo ve
y yo creo que sí porque draghi es lo que
llamaríamos un buen ejemplo del
nacionalismo italiano bien decía mario
no ha sido un político en términos de
cargos políticos por elección acepta
este nombramiento porque tiene reconoce
la responsabilidad que representa
entonces yo creo que la presión social
ciudadana así que podría surtir efecto
pero también la presión
europea internacional y de los mercados
que en el anuncio de la dimisión
la bolsa italiana se tambaleó por allí
entonces creo que las dos presiones si
podrían hacer que draghi
más se mantenga en el gobierno con un
nuevo gobierno es decir sin el
movimiento cinco estrellas al mando
escalando esto un poco más allá de las
fronteras italianas pasando al escenario
de la unión europea una italia inestable
una italia con constantes crisis
políticas otra vez con la necesidad de
tener que conformar un gobierno que
representa para la unión europea que
tanto peso tiene italia a nivel político
dentro de la unión
una de las paradojas del excepcionalismo
italiano es este fue derrotada en la
segunda guerra mundial era enemiga de
los aliados y se convirtió en uno de los
países fundadores de las uniones de la
unión europea y es la tercera economía
de la unión europea después de alemania
y francia y la segunda industria después
de alemania por supuesto que italia
tiene un peso muy importante y por eso
es importante está el mantener la
estabilidad pero como mencionábamos al
principio la inestabilidad política
italiana no es
desconocida
a la política europea por eso mencionó
un poco la presión que puede venir no
solo de la ciudadanía sino por parte del
entorno europeo para mantener a draghi
porque un primer ministro que se venga a
la calma en italia es lo que necesita
europa para hacer frente a los retos que
hemos mencionado en la invasión rusa
ucrania que la crisis económica y la
crisis climática además lo vemos muy
activo en la jornada de hoy estuvo en
argel negociando precisamente con el
gobierno argelino para que le suministre
gas a través de diferentes gasoductos
que ya hay activos a través del
mediterráneo eso lo convierte en un país
que se vuelve una primera puerta de
entrada a la unión europea de otro
suministro de gas diferente al que ya
tienen o han tenido hasta el momento por
medio de rusia también vemos a ursula
von der leyen negociando en azerbaiyán
también un cuotas de suministro de gas
desde bakú hasta hasta los balcanes
en este marco de la crisis energética
que está bien
mario que está viendo todo el continente
europeo y eso que el invierno pues
todavía no ha comenzado faltan todavía
unos meses para eso que es tal vez el
momento más crítico esta posición por
ejemplo de hoy de mario draghi en
argelia negociando estos suministros de
gas le da una posición privilegiada a
italia para poder solventar esa esa
crisis energética esto le da un una
posición digamos un poco de ventaja
italia y puede darle a draghi también
una posición de ventaja a nivel político
suponiendo que se quede en el gobierno
sí pero tenemos que pensar una cosa en
que no pensemos tanto en la edad ventaja
a italia italia digamos sigue siendo un
país sigue existiendo pero ya no se
busca tanto la ganancia
personal como país tenemos que entender
un poco lo que es la esencia de la unión
europea hacia dónde va
esta búsquedas los bienes comunes aunque
el gasoducto entre por italia y es por
italia porque ese gas de argelia antes
entrada por españa pero como españa hizo
el lo que para argelia fue una tradición
en política exterior al reconocer la
soberanía de marruecos sobre el sobre el
sáhara occidental al chile y españa
ahora mismo no está muy bien entonces
hay que darle a argelia que es el que
más gas nos va a dar hay que buscarle un
nuevo amigo al que le pueda dar mucho
ese gas
italia es el de ahora el gasoducto que
mencionabas de von der leyen que está en
en azerbayán ese gasoducto va a venir
por turquía nos va a haber que llegar a
alguna con erdogán con quien ya llegó
con la crisis de refugiados hay que
llegar a un acuerdo con él también con
los países de los balcanes que aún no
son una europea pero están tocando la
puerta quieren ser candidatos está
diciendo estos días si montenegro al
perdón encontraron más hacia el norte
ahora ya van a ser
se les iban ser países candidatos
entonces digamos que es algo más grande
que solo fijarnos en lo que italia diga
yo voy a ganar y más draghi que es un
hombre que donde se ha hecho
mayor percibirlo en deshecho importante
es en las instituciones europeas en la
presidencia el banco central europeo-
claro importante ese papel destacado que
ha tenido él en los organismos
internacionales voy llegando ya la recta
final de el programa vamos cerrando
entonces y vamos llegando también a las
conclusiones de lo que puede suceder en
este escenario político de lo que puede
suceder el miércoles en ese discurso que
tiene que dar draghi ante el parlamento
italiano y de lo que pueda suceder de
allí en adelante usted cómo lo ve
armando que puede que esa ante qué
escenario nos podemos enfrentar el
miércoles
yo me quedo en el escenario en que
draghi continúa por estos elementos que
hemos mencionado durante el programa
para agotar la legislatura porque la
estabilidad política es lo que necesita
italia y europa frente al escenario
regional e internacional
y manny a usted que piensa que podemos
ver el miércoles que escenario podemos
estar viendo
pues estoy de acuerdo con armando opción
número uno la principal
y fraga
mayor
mariola de ir por favor y retomemos que
retomé que retomé la respuesta porque se
cortó la señal de internet en ese
momento y no podemos entender entonces
le pido por favor que retomé
vale lo siento inicio nuevamente
entonces yo coincidió con hermandad en
que la opción número uno es que draghi
siga pero cinco estrellas se va a ir del
gobierno con los otros seis partidos que
siga el gobierno y la parte de cinco
estrellas que apoya a draghi todavía le
seguirá apoyando puntualmente hasta que
se agotará la legislatura
y por lo que sea deciden no seguir un
tecnócrata un término verdad también con
cinco estrellas fuera del gobierno la
opción ultimísima serían elecciones
porque no le interesa ni al presidente
material de lo que tiene con que tiene
el que tiene que convocarlas ni europa
ni a los famosos mercados no les
interesa y van a presionar según todo su
armamento para que no ocurra y armando
que puede pasar entonces con movimiento
cinco estrellas como lo explica mario
draghi se queda se pueden quedar algunos
de sus representantes que son a fin un
poco más cercanos a las ideas que
propone draghi que puede pasar entonces
con este partido qué suerte puede tener
dentro del espectro político italiana
pasaría a ser oposición directa al
gobierno de draghi junto y no creo que
sea un buen escenario con el partido de
ultraderecha en enero del panismo que
son los hermanos de italia por lo tanto
por eso creo que el movimiento de cinco
estrellas podría ir hacia la baja como
ha ido de 2018 para acá y no representar
una nueva opción sobre todo porque se
les cae el discurso de antisistema si
han estado ya en diferentes gobiernos
y mário su percepción qué puede pasar
con este movimiento político dado el
caso que le toque retirarse de la
coalición solamente dejar algunos
integrantes que son afines a la ciudad
de drive
pues como dice armando la opción que
tienen es juntarse en la oposición con
fratelli d'italia que es tratar de
mezclar el agua y el aceite con lo cual
eso es imposible entonces van a pasar a
la irrelevancia
o se aclaran ellos mismos dentro y
arreglan su casa o desaparecen porque se
van a ver a la irrelevancia
es importante decir aquí tengo entre mis
notas que la única oposición formal que
tiene el gobierno italiano en este
momento son los que nos mencionan los
otros hermanos de italia en donde
giorgia meloni es quien lidera desde
hace meses las encuestas a nivel
ciudadano quienes son estas figuras
políticas armando ya para el cierre del
programa quiénes son
giorgia meloni es la dirigente de este
movimiento de este partido que es el
heredero del racismo en italia y en su
momento el partido de sal viniera la
ultraderecha los hermanos de cal ya
están más a la derecha todavía al
extremo de la derecha son un partido
realmente
populista nacionalista xenófobo con la
idea justamente de italia para los
italianos si un escenario complicado
-mario unos minutos para añadir algo de
lo que pueda suceder en italia lo que se
viene para los próximos semanas en
cuanto al desempeño de este país al
interior de la unión europea e
inestabilidad de su gran conclusión para
el cierre del programa
vale italia como hemos dicho siempre ha
sido lo que llamaríamos inestable pero
nunca ha implosionado el estado como tal
entonces en esa inestabilidad tenemos
que ver que quizás hay una virtud que no
alcanzamos a ver es italiano no va a
desaparecer nos va a llamar la atención
porque no es lo que se está acostumbrado
más aquí en latinoamérica es un sistema
muy raro el hablar de un sistema
parlamentario donde haya tanto cambio no
se termina entre entonces italia va a
seguir siendo importante
el gobierno que salga seguramente casi
fijo cuando se agote esta legislatura y
en primavera del año que viene vuelvo a
ver elecciones
tenderá a ser un gobierno moderado de
común como digamos centro o
centroderecha porque todos van a tratar
de evitar
llegar a acuerdo con fratelli d'italia
fratelli d'italia será el apestado en
esa campaña claro para entrar al
gobierno bueno pues ya lo veremos en la
primavera boreal del año entrante a ver
qué gobierno se puede conformar en
italia en esas elecciones por el momento
veremos qué sucede el miércoles en la
decisión que toma mario draghi ante el
parlamento mario armando les agradezco
mucho por haber puesto en perspectiva ha
explicado y habernos aclarado en todos
los temas aquí referentes que tratamos a
la política italiana ustedes muchas
gracias también por haber participado en
el programa a través de las preguntas y
comentarios que dejan en las redes
sociales y también aprovecho para
despedirme de las personas que nos oyen
a través de nuestro podcast en las
diferentes plataformas en las que
estamos en los recuerdos rápidamente app
el podcast spotify deezer i tunes in
sigan con france24
[Música]